thursday is cinco de mayo and if you're
looking to celebrate you should check
out the festivities at casa playa and
win in las vegas and here with more is
executive chef sarah thompson welcome to
the show thank you for having me this is
a broad question but what do you guys
have planned for for thursday i mean
it's going to be a huge party we got
bongo players we have a guitar um we
have a few specialty cocktails that
we're going to make a spicy fashion
fruit margarita and then we're going to
have a special food for the night we're
going to have a taste of castle playa
where you can taste our crispy skin
carnitas our berea our carne asada
lobster house made chorizo all served
with tortillas and salsas all made in
house so you can really get a taste of
what we're putting together there you
guys make everything in-house we do yeah
we get all of our ingredients from
mexico we make all of our tortillas
fresh all of our chilies all of these
specialty ingredients come in uh from
mexico every day and you know we make a
really beautiful experience what you're
telling me is that you guys are the real
deal exactly you're the real deal what
are you gonna make for us today so we're
gonna make our wagou carne asada tacos
which is our most popular dish in our
menu we actually saw more of it than our
wash so we're going to make some
tortillas okay this is what a tortilla
maker is this is a tortilla yes yeah i
think it's the first time we've had a
tortilla press on las vegas now really
this is the first time i don't know if
you've had one before i've been here
this is going to be your first tortilla
that you make too yes it is okay so
perfect we're going to press it down
obviously we want it to be nice and
round because you don't want to have a
not round tortilla you want it nice and
ready
you're going to put it on your three or
four fingers and you're just going to
lay it really gently in this pan okay
now people watching they can make
reservations for thursday do you
recommend reservations i would 100
recommend
reservations we already have over 300
covers on the books it's going to be a
really busy night but we also we're
going to put something on top real quick
um but you know we still have plenty of
room for you guys to come in uh we're
great for large parties we have a lot of
you know big tables encourage group
dining so bring all your friends and you
know enjoy some drinks i don't have to
push that hard on yeah you them
we're already there
a little bit that's nice that's nice you
guys like that i'm so proud of myself
oh my god my mom is watching she's so
proud of me right now okay what's the
next step making these okay we're gonna
you have to let's open this up
very thin i guess you want all the meat
on here about 45 seconds i'm going to
let you take charge of what you're
making here
i'll slide back over here i'll just put
together this taco real quick then and
as you're making this one more time on
the drinks because they sounded really
good i feel like we've got a breeze over
there the spicy passion fruit margarita
and then another variation of a
margarita with uh hibiscus and
grapefruit it's going to be so good i
cannot wait to try them and you guys do
wagu beef we do i mean nothing but the
fat that's that's the top end beef is it
not yeah no like i said nothing but the
best well marbled uh you know black is
actually looking for marbles to get some
fat and is it fat
some flavor exactly fat is flavor
and then
voila
cannot go wrong
i like how i like how awesome this is
the first time we had a tortilla maker
here this is the first time that the
chef made something and you hate it
yourself this is good you got to eat it
right you made it you got to eat it i
love it chef i know you're going to do
this
don't waste it